new rules Donald Trump is the grown-up
version of every pain-in-the-ass kid who
ever sat behind you on a plane kicking
the back of your seat while the parents
did nothing little Logan is just
exploring no little Logan is being a
dick and if you won't shove him in the
overhead bin I will stop trying to pin
the rise of Donald Trump on easy targets
like racism xenophobia and fetal alcohol
syndrome and put the blame where it
belongs on the self-esteem movement have
you noticed that nobody ever does
anything better than Donald Trump nobody
builds walls better than me I will be
the greatest job president nobody knows
the system better nobody would be
tougher on Isis nobody loves the Bible
more there's nobody better at the Milot
I could be more presidential than
anybody he really said all those things
Trump is the perfect candidate for the
country that scores low in math and
science but off the charts in
self-esteem a study of eight developed
countries found that US students were
dead last in math skills but number one
in confidence in math skills
yes we're number one in thinking we're
number one and when the numbers don't
validate that confidence we change the
numbers in the 60s at Yale ten percent
of all grades were A's now it's 62%
Donald Trump is the epitome of what they
say on reality shows
hey the most important thing is just you
doing you yeah but what of you is a big